despite the massive success that you've
had you still get mistaken for another
celebrity for Daniel Radcliffe would get
mistaken for hidden still happens now
this this started happening after you
know the Lord of the Rings had come out
and then it was sort of consequently
happening with the Harry Potter films
and very shortly after people started to
mistake me for Daniel and apparently
Daniel was mistaken for me mm-hmm
and this kind of after a while you think
it like hits the internet and becomes a
thing and people talk about it for a
while and you think ok we get it like
it's the the joke is over and it'll die
but it just it has long legs and it just
keeps going there's a there's a gif of
you turning into Daniel yeah and back
into you and it's extremely popular on
the Internet it's been 8 viewed 15
million times 15 million times and I
think you get $10 each time it's viewed
that we're true know if this thing is
everywhere but just take a look at this
it's eerie that the transformation is so
subtle that it's creepy
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an eyebrow range it just looks like
it's you raising and lowering your
eyebrows Harry Potter Frodo
Harry Potter I go to this this Film
Festival we every year called Fantastic
Fest and they do this thing called the
fantastic debates which effectively is
two people in a boxing ring as it turns
out debating a topic each person debates
the topic and then they have a rebuttal
and then they actually box they actually
fight each other after a debate yeah so
a proper debate and then they they it's
fisticuffs right so I've done this
before and for the longest time they
wanted to get Daniel Radcliffe and I to
do it and it almost became a thing this
year and I ultimately squashed it cuz I
was like I don't want to find one to
fight this guy I don't want the
culmination of the fact that we look
alike or somehow get mistaken for each
other to end up being in a boxing ring
so it didn't end up happening you know
what you say to the de Poisson
disappointment of a lot of it you
shouldn't do that but you should
definitely do it on pay-per-view because
people would tune in I mean people would
go crazy is that still a thing
this pay-per-view events yes so you can
still do direct right there sure you can
pay to see a boxing match hosting boxing
stuff they said that Elijah Wood and
Daniel Radcliffe are gonna go at it and
you have to each be dressed as your
characters
you get it you get a sword he has a wand
yeah and magic is [ __ ] wrestling
yeah Russell if you like expiry and
you'd be like Jack that's blood coming
out or confetti
stomping him with those big hairy feet
dude I love this is the end of you
you